I'm told that you have a special
background that you made just just for
me that you wanted to show me is that
right
no I have a special background just fee
it's not I don't know if it'll fit the
screen yeah
oh my god I know what that is what is it
yes look at that that's when you came on
my show and you demonstrated a slap for
me that's right I slapped you slap me
and I remembered you were a little
worried before the show I knew you were
gonna slap me you were a little worried
about and I said the only way this is
gonna work is if you really go for it
yeah you were you were great school I
have to say that's the hardest I've been
hit in my life I'm so sorry don't be
sorry it was great people loved it
people loved it online but I thought
well I hope she goes for it and then you
went for it and you are strong and you
we got really drunk on the show like you
made me do I think I did that could
sound bad I didn't make a date we did
three shot I think three shots of
tequila like on the stage and I had to
go and get on a flight right off smashed
through customs it's the best way to to
get on a flight it is is with the good
buzz